um so one sided migrate cuz the Moose
are coming not sure what that means but
that's aspects cool cool
Kramer what are you gonna do after this
what are you gonna do now that it's
midnight in Los Angeles you're gonna go
out you're gonna real where you hit the
club we're going should we go out Kramer
sure haha we should where should we go
you know best we're sort of in the
Burbank area I feel like we might have
to go to West Hollywood yeah I live in
West Hollywood was Hollywood's a good
time and we should do that why not
what's what's like there's gotta be a
show made me so planning right like
something yet like a movie we go see
movies movie
I have movie past you movie past I don't
but I'll just buy a ticket there what
that work what movie are we seeing
though 50 shades of grey okay hard bad
no I said okay no no I really want to go
see that I'm not gonna judge you for
that I okay
someone says all right peace dream
they're switching over the yeah we're
switching it over so find the new link
migrate over that means they have to
doesn't mean after migrate no it just
means that they're they might and I see
link there's new links Tim Coco's
posting new links Alexis out Alexis
wants a shout out Alexis fire hey girl
what's up how's it going this is why we
need to move in New York City we should
move to New York City I mean on a movie
remember we've been in New York City
together before a lot and we party hard
in New York we were in that cab that one
time
wait there are a lot of times that's
crazy
New York cab for the San Diego cab no in
New York New York and we know but I'm
kind of
Cabarete it was I'm talking with a New
York cab ride was that like after we
left that bar in Midtown and were I
don't know joking I didn't know you were
like thinking of a specific cab ride
super much there was a camera which what
happened we went we got everybody back
to the hotel safely okay except leeway
this is just like the Vegas story or
like nothing happened well it was the
end of the night you got if you want to
say at the beginning of the night
there's all sorts of debauch memories
like remember that cab ride story we had
where we got everyone back the hotel
safely that was so cool we got everyone
back safely and we got in the cab from
the bar and it took us to the hotel it
was great yeah what oh yeah I did is
this you joke but I seriously got
everybody back safely which is a feat in
and of itself
you're probably right because you're
crazy I didn't know there was rules for
which side of the cab you could get into
in New York and I tried to go like on
the street side and like open the door
and the guy was like no no yeah yeah
it's like real is the real rules there
and in LA and when you're in that mover
you just do what you want and in
Michigan when your friends driving you
because they're the DD you really do
whatever you want you leti drive up on
the grass and just like barrel roll into
the car on that note we're gonna
introduce oh yeah that's it for us we're
done we're wrapping it up our co-workers
coworkers deep deep friends nerds
they're finishing making their drinks
right now smoothies their health
smoothies with protein powder and
flannel couch it's really gotta get that
positive
how early morning like goodness Eric
okay Eric
[Applause]
that was a great run guys we've got my
smoothie there hey what's that pod
it's a Internet what's up Internet all
right all right we got our smoothies all
blended up and ready to go yeah we do
this exciting because this is gonna be a
marathon yeah it is as amigo yeah hmm
that's the kale mm-hmm does a deep kale
taste can't they want to know if you
just came from a sauna or something no I
mean you know I figured when playing
video games you gotta wear your rope I
always play video games my robe at home
so I called ahead and Ruthie said it was
okay to wear a wear a robe and who do we
have here this is Jake the puggle Jake
he likes me he likes video games too
he's our mascot here at a Conan he sits
here and you build in for Kramer when
Kramer can't come in he's a big fan of
carrots he's healthy boys carrots enjoy
so I'm Eric and this is Kent yeah and we
are both cute cards good yes we're both
cute card guys right into that that is
your name yeah yeah
we both do cute cards for the Conan
O'Brien show is that right kid sometimes
we do and today we're gonna be playing
yeah Star Wars galaxy of Heroes yay
exciting just for the occasion oh that's
from the flight starts to get really
good and if we have enough time we're
gonna get into Star Wars Knights of the
Old Republic
it's exciting that's good I felt chills
I don't know what I fell but there is
tingling in my loins I guess maybe those
are chills
can you save loins you can say - all
right that's just a good good let's
party that's party all right so yeah we
do we do cards on the Conan O'Brien show
I've been with the show too long too
long no yeah well I started as an intern
with Kramer at that
Conan's first resurrection in LA and now
really good you're in Kramer's class I'm
in Kramer's class Wow
we were the head of the class well
Kramer was like the a student and I was
like so the people that are like C
students that's me and somehow here we
are he had a better time slot than me so
that says a lot about what's going on
around here nobody you can't I I don't
even know I don't even know where I am
right now it's happening oh we're
halfway through we're supposed to
announce that we are officially halfway
through the team cocoa Google plays
24-hour mobile marathon is so exciting
we're so excited to be here yes we are
doing it people these guys been doing
such a great job everybody in this whole
room has been doing amazing yes I have
to put my sweetie down good so fun how
do you guys stay in the business since
cue cards can so easily be replaced
never be replaced
well we're actually both robots so
that's how that works I'd I'd eat I
dreamt I was a robot last night that's
weird that you said Tess Wow all right
yeah yes filk a dick
good good West Kramer yeah Kramer Jack's
like an hour and a half wasn't long
enough for him he's amazing yeah but men
just butting in all right so where's
bleh - show us how to play this oh yeah
sitting at the cantina for hours oh oh
we're on we're up this is nice plain
Star Wars
we've got a galaxy of the heroes once
again look at these guys I know
look there's Jabba and this looks like a
place I was in West Hollywood at last
night there's a who's that ron jeremy is
that a joke yeah okay the Rainbow Room
yeah yes so we have Cantina battles we
have shipments we have the store we have
the squad arena those are are they
locked okay interlocked we can't play at
everything yet so we can only go to the
store that's song well I'm gonna click
on things into activities we can play do
some activity it turns out where the
hand is pointing to yes well that's what
they want you to do oh yeah hey somebody
said bleh is dead it makes sense nuts
that doesn't bode well for us learning
how to play this game
Cantina pad wait okay here we go let's
continue to the next battle they're
battling to get a slight saber in our
hands this is where you set your your
squad okay okay are we gonna have squad
goals that's what I want to know
everybody on instagram has these gone -
tagging the hash tag squad altering this
hash tag you're getting close to filling
it up I don't know what they're talking
about it I'm I'm just hitting buttons
here we go we're gonna battle alright
there's some stuff then you're playing
man sorry yeah sorry we don't have
volume you're the Jedi Knight I have
some cue cards from the one year
anniversary show of Conan Conan did
didn't like some jokes and handle them
to me hahahaha well good for you just
don't sell them on eBay so we can talk
to everybody yeah they're right here we
have oh there's legs small yeah
we're also they're singing Disney songs
to us Congrats on the Oscar win you know
thanks for watching hello robe guy dude
I love it I'll be robe guy who doesn't
play with video games in robes actually
I don't call this my robe I call this my
Conan skin suit
because he's so white no I would never
wear conan is a skin suit all right your
your Jedi Knight and I okay here we go
is it just one controller
there's no controllers kit this is
Google Play so you play this on your
Google you know my Android your Android
or I yes where are is yes yeah okay cuz
forget all those other ones oh yeah
Chewie just the old crib they shoot back
okay that's what happens
oh it's like a turn-based yeah okay I'm
getting destroyed yeah yeah kill it guys
do that oh there there we go
yes blue yeah so do that well there it
is
oh okay look at this okay the volume up
on this chop that oj eleven-year-old
puddle this game is student who loves to
I disagree there aren't stupid games
only stupid people ways to eat carrots
loves carrots great eyesight on this dog
he does Jake's how old he's 11 going on
for and you've been fostering him for
since he was since he fit in my hand
since he was since he was like 5 months
old
ok we got the sound work
there's that there's that fun Star Wars
sound craving once again we're playing
Star Wars Galaxies of heroes on the team
cocoa Google plays 24-hour mobile
marathon and we do key cards on the show
well I'm excited
I'm definitely getting this game after
this just I'm so just based on the sound
effects I killed we killed three people
we didn't read any of the instructions
to the game no this guy asked how high
are you how dare you sir how dare you
Romo pilots like Bill Ponderosa who's
pill Ponderosa
I wish mines anybody who build
ponderosas you know what I always
thought would be a great name Dan
bandana who that would be that'd be
pretty cool here is pug mix yeah puggle
he's at his half hog half beagle got the
Beagle ears got the Beagle ears somebody
says we're gonna need a refill on those
carrots soon how and why did we become
cue card guys
well how does anybody become anything my
uncle invented them his uncle actually
did invent cue cards and this is a true
story the ESN around over here was a
true story in 1956-57 first cue card on
the edwin show at CBS he was a page he
was 16 years old and he was a page with
James Dean there was 16 years old
together and I swear to God
and Edwin came in hammered every day and
he couldn't remember his lines so he
wrote up key cards for man that sounded
started surely that is true look it up
and then you know and then he kind of
became Bob Hope's go-to guy right he did
he was Bob Hope's dude for many years
and saved his life so Bob Bob got it
someone with saving his life what degree
do you need to do you need to have to be
a cue card holder um
what degree ya wanna kindergarten hour
tops you have to be a black belt do you
have two hands neither of them broken
you can do cue cards set your squad I
love this hashtag squad all right I
think we're prepared for battle now
Jake's ready put the Buddha belly you're
gonna get a little brother mm-hmm tap it
I'm tapping it Wham ha whoo yeah Oh
slice slice eat I see
oh you knock it off dude oh I gotta get
him when they're not shooting I
understand now there we go light saber
BAM yeah
come on somebody doing something whatchu
he's gettin it not anymore
please wait am too you're crushing
progress thanks man nice nice and I see
nope nope wow this is incredible you can
play this on your phone you can do this
on your phone anything that supports
Google Play how having good time Jake
you're loving it victory that's all all
we do here at Conan is continue to win
and everybody online is gonna hate me
for saying that that's alright though
[Music]
that was pretty fun navigate the Colden
wases of Hoth to face Imperials new
troopers let's do that okay your
possible enemy can I have a carrot for
use vert for winning sure actually here
I don't want to take it from Jake not
sorry how can we share giving away shirt
can we share this get it together don't
eat together get in there yeah get in
there
ah yeah ma'am great there you go good
job guys everybody wanted I've been
watching this feet all you know all day
and it just keeps asking people to kiss
so do you eat broccoli before you can I
did mm-hmm
baked broccoli bait what's happening now
yeah I'm confused
Oh characters that's tap trained select
your Jedi assigned the training droid
all right we're training
look how much power you have I have so
much power and they want you to talk
more about uh about uh about cue cards
while I play so if you want to the white
um here they're really twenty-two inches
long
here's the two sizes that were you
usually only frothy I brought these I
figured people want to know check it out
check it this is a cute card right there
so corn reads that everyday conan reads
the monologue off of it he reads his
sketches off the bandages off of it the
intros and outros were up there and then
Andy I'm around he's at his lectern so
he needs a little bit smaller card yeah
somebody asked why do we still use cue
cards without a prompter well a lot of
the times people aren't looking directly
at the camera so the eye lines need a
little feel a little bit off and that's
why you use cue cards you can run around
prompters or transfixed to the camera
stuck to it shows that use cue cards
speaking of stuff uh SNL Jimmy Fallon
Seth Meyers yeah any late-night talk
show only sitcom not any sick not any
sitcoms
[Music]
man I got my pubes from them can't you
run around with a digital card mm-hmm
but probably one battle away from
claiming that daily activity reward
let's go there now I'll narrate press 96
battle six oh boy
Hannah got pizza there's Pizza Pizza oh
crap I gotta kill people all right here
we go
Graham okay I don't like
Raja 11 come on here in Newtown yes
here is an doggy's tree oh good dog
wants pizza on him I love this because
it keeps putting out on the dog emoji
hey this guy said dog on head how's that
we're people pleasers it's what we do
dog dog on handle damage to prove to the
internet we're not we're not false
images
come on Pizza where's the pizza from
okay I'm sorry can we say who can we say
oh we can't say we can't say with the
pizzas from it's from Burbank Boulevard
yeah we're beautiful downtown Burbank
rush what do you want from me burn at
least things are happening we're not
watching security footage for slice
ladies victory victory is on three stars
man what you get what we get
we got crystals I tell you got remotes
we're about to become the heroes 6x
galaxy of heroes you want to trade and I
hold Jay can you play I've got more
treats form to mr. Vega I got this thing
and a bound people probably thought this
was a this is a bone actually that's
like those bacon-wrapped sticks that
they have people I have a feeling people
thought this was something else but it's
a delirium my way over
Oh Jake what are you going but oh it on
the other side of it can I touch all
these bone I don't treat like here we go
oh yeah okay clean completed our first
daily activity let's go claim your
reward 10 XP that is
we leveled up too - Eric Oh bonus energy
snapping - oh so now we can go to the
store yeah I see yeah we can we can buy
some stuff because we've been killing it
oh oh yeah at least a hundred years old
confirm wait oh no I did something I
should know you play as guest we can
choose her name okay what do you say Dan
bandana Dan bandana I like to assume he
wears like Tommy Bahama shirts all the
time that would have been good I brought
him a row but we didn't have time to go
get it the dogger me both oh okay Jake
you were really getting after this okay
we got chili we got a clone trooper oh
and is that like Mace Windu's cousin
nerd dude it Mace Windu's Samuel L cross
City
[Music]
oh no wait how do we level up argues
press the only effect for deeds all
enemies will target this you oh I see
maybe like ones dying a little bit too
much you know oh wait I think it's
perfect
what's your workout routine to keep up
with the cue card can't do you do a lot
of shoulder exercises to hold the cue
cards maybe a lot of wrist exercise
what's this a my right arm is really
strong and that's nothing to do with cue
cards I feel sorry for you Jake - fifty
oh yeah come on
slice and dice suckas slice dice crush
it wait
dude he can't do that to chew and you're
like we continue to play the same level
over and over again might just be me no
man now there now Warren Hoth making our
way through Hoth or the blood the blast
doors to the base so we're getting close
mmm this prize yes what is blue shirt
guy's name
it's Erik so now you can start crapping
on me
critical damage see see a snow trooper
[Music]
Star Wars Galaxies Jake oh my daddy
slice and dice it up what's this
oh I healed all right people doesn't
matter we're heals you're done watch
almost now your success
[Music]
Wow now look we're under the Falken oh
come on yeah let's get on it what do we
want a little slice and dice to start it
off
you're really figuring this out he
resisted it this guy's crafty
[Music]
[Applause]
snow you later sucker victory again all
this winning is making me listen yeah we
had a loss yeah we leveled up we're
already up to level three you guys who's
done this all night nobody nobody has
dominated again quite like us Jake maybe
he was crushing that bone Jake's back -
it is a victory yeah I love her I don't
know who this is
man she's beautiful right gorgeous she's
at why lack because she has the UH
that's the race with the the things that
come down do you think it mandibles to
come off your head the mandible got that
headband gone mm-hmm do you think that's
a smoke required in there I don't know
but they're catering to me in this game
on a piece of gear all right what gear
each character uses ah now it's getting
super involved like we were so high what
art what are you gonna gain uh you got
in the game where's our score is very
high and we have the high score you guys
leave us alone with you know they they
drug test for cue cards so it's a
prerequisite unlike most artists and yes
we are artists claiming my rewards
you're claiming your rewards yeah
claimed do you know that a claim leveled
up again and I didn't do anything
we're that good do you know that
dominoes heads like we're words now you
can click reward I'm sorry never mind
do you know pizza places don't have a
pizza pizza
let's see check back later for more
bonus energy fight a dollar for
everything the girl told me that okay
all right well how much how much do you
get paid as a cue card guy so much you
can come down here don't they give you
all my money is anybody watching right
now my pockets down we both have pool
houses you come you stay with us come to
LA just email us at pool house at
google.com and you just come you stay
with us hold on a second I've got we
have an inbox should we check to see
what messages yeah oh we have friends a
canteen a gift pack is that loot good
messages limited time gift
Luke is a gift to us he's gifting us
Mark Hamill Wow this is a true story
just knowing I was six years old or
seven when I walked out of Empire
Strikes Back I went and started taking
gymnastics lessons and I put lemon juice
lemon juice in my hair
Juiz to turn it blonde to be like Mark
Hamill because he took gymnastics for
Empire Strikes Back to learn how to use
the Force and when Yoda was teaching
when he was doing all the flips and all
the fun stuff
I heard he did that so it made it set me
on a path if you will
to become Luke Skywalker and I put lemon
juice in my hair I still to chimney yes
now I just do mental gymnastics everyday
with Conan all right we've got Skywalker
so if that story proves anything kids
it's that um lemon juice doesn't lemon
juice pass to your hair it doesn't do
crap to your hair okay no I think he
just gave you a gift
Oh somebody just said you're the guy who
went to 160 fish shows that's correct
get has been the whoa now it's like 180
yeah 180 it'll be a lot more after the
summer can't Rosie says sandwich so my
friend Rosie Michael Rosenbaum maybe are
you coming down here you did he was
maybe gonna come down
he he's uh we're in a band together
called the sandwich I thought this story
was going so story the sandwich we just
hi we got just got was you scared all
over you know was a scientist got
squirreled mom whoa whenever somebody
has to think about it there is no next
sure there is no next show right now
we're actually we got invited to play in
Frankfurt in the fall and a music
festival but that's not that's it's
spring when that's in the fall so that's
not for a while but um soon soon well
Jake well we'll get everyone it'll be
fun
all right so we're gonna Catan as Luke
he's back they'll never miss one second
well there's a lot of stuff to tap
lightside bowels let's do that do we
wanna go to a Star Destroyer I guess
that's all we can do well II what we
might so everybody that's chatting right
now where are you guys at in the world
oh nice feel Republic yeah
is it be not start giving some shoutouts
were you guys were you guys that right
now it's currently 12 we should be 41
Australia Germany Pitts first filly
Switzerland Cincinnati Croatia Seattle
Michigan again Phoenix California lay
chill a people have chosen Chile Chicago
Rock City youths in touch new this New
York news people in Michigan it's great
Flint there we go Tennessee Sacramento
9:42 a.m. and the water that a throwed
says Samuel Samuel oh you got to kill
people dude how did Ann Arbor yes
Toronto Finland Chico California piano
Texas Slovenia Chile
I love the Chewbacca roaring at them
kills them did he like cute do you
harder Malaysia apart Jakarta was rehab
North Korea I'm from Wisconsin
what's up Wisconsin come on you can't
watch this in North Korea Kentrell hurry
now
Wisconsin or Korea's again Nepal Saudi
Arabia Saudi Arabia yeah Riyadh Maine
what's up from Germany are you from
Dover dude run by bands playing in
Frankfurt in the fall comes why the the
Rockwood events Rocklin Molokai you have
lepers that melt
malabon Netherlands Austria dinner early
are you guys just writing countries or
is this really people from all these
place some of them are States
Italy Slovakia it's like is this real
yes it's Morgan desert-y Wow Jake it's
Jake Jake's had enough too I mean it got
a little intense for this guys from Hoth
oh I know I know that's dry hey Gary
cannon just said coming weekend show all
tickets are free
Gary kid it's our warm-up guy on Conan
and love you is awful that I love
anything
Gary if you've ever yeah we call him
Gary cannon because literally all he
does is throw t-shirt Antarctica that's
such confident in Antarctica
he's a cannon of t-shirt Alderaan
where do you where do you how do you
find love you're in Alderaan places I
laugh too hard for that I'm really mad
at myself
that's a good joke what's your what's
your actual favorite mobile mobile game
goodness shoot
mine is cribbage cribbage the card game
the one where you read the one where you
slide down the things and there's
Cline's no the mostly slide you're like
Indiana Jones was this was this
acquisition asset tree last weekend
Temple Run yeah
just a reminder we're burning star wars
galaxy of Heroes Star Trek star wars
wars that's a toughy man because they're
so different but they're so different I
can't even get into it I'm not
but they both really yeah well I mean
one one's a space opera fantasy and one
is straight sci-fi you know so they're
they're different in the Sean or a
battle alone no I'm gonna end up doing
like George slants you know if you want
to see a great Oh final encounter yeah I
just realized I was gonna get thrown by
Jacob honor no I said hell they played
anyways I got a boner get your minds out
of the gutter sometimes he does it's not
I'm gonna be a big deal if he did or
what is good that air that you got intro
money all right chicken I'll see you
soon he'll be back Jake second is his
Union so he needs to take it go on at a
power break it's kind of like a child
actor on set he needs to go to his dog
training classes he's got a bowl of
gravy for bullet or he's gonna drink it
is it a turkey or chicken or beef gravy
it's it's a roadkill Roach blender a
roadkill Oh with little cumin look you
know tarragon in there human look Avery
nice how annoyed are you guys might say
slice every time he uses lightsaber and
a scale of 1 to 10 so yeah but everyone
guys are awesome they're awesome mr.
pickles I like Jordans star yes Jordans
Star Trek star war speech you don't hear
me Jabbar on earth no water
Jordans thing on scraps on Team Coco
calm how do I feel about the prequels
dude I mean the first one that you know
look the fan of the Phantom Menace og is
kind of unnecessary it's kind of
unnecessary now if you look at the
machete order it takes it out completely
and I'd have to say I kind of agree
except for Liam Neeson was fantastic and
qui gonn star wars is not lame bash this
nerd come on man just ours is like part
of the cultural fabric it's like a it's
like a Joseph Campbell and it's just
like the the age-old - you know time
trodden story of good versus evil and
light versus dark it's we'll just keep
playing then Joseph Campbell in the
Internet
Pesche I'll see Luke rushes in this game
yet another victory victory we don't
lose see what the chia seed shake tastes
like hmm there's a lot of seeds in there
oh I got some more rewards I see rewards
points yeah mmm do I want to continue
sure go cash shut-ins for some yes I
mean we have we won yet can we write a
few cards while taping I feel like
there's yes we do I mean we'll get
changes up until uh guy wants you to
draw did you see what he wanted to draw
that's no it's gross that's gross sir
can't draw wieners new bonds oh did my
dog just dig just wiped his butt on the
floor he's did it this guy wants you to
write pubes cubes cubes that's a great
word I like to stretch it out when I say
at pubes you can say okay what also we
got select off squad assign a squad
configuration I like Luke man he's uh
he's serious beeswax Oh and Chewie of
course
and then the Jedi oh oh we already did
all that confirm your squad hashtag
confirmed squad goals
[Music]
battle let's do this for the young kids
Star Wars is basically oh come on wait
so many people don't even know what Star
Wars is got you do less Jedi just came
out of course you don't it's impossible
what are you talking about so these
action is this actually live we're
reading what you're saying what kind of
question is that can you play something
other than there's anything live can you
play something other than yeah yeah how
about Star Wars
you know wait is what we're waiting we
can we can play another game we can play
jeez Louise Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic yeah I'm down with that you
wanna play that no I'm bored no we
haven't lost at this game yet dude said
I like Chewie Oh
we pretty much finished the game there's
really no we haven't lost anything
Desmond Malone definitely not live this
is live definitely not live that's been
Malone definitely not live this has been
you're not lying you're not live yeah
you're fake now what's up thought yeah
you're a bot you're a bot
troll all just BOTS hashtag troll play
fortnight
can we play fortnight no that's not over
playing google play games right now
let's not walk on correct no I love it I
love when people say this is garbage and
yet they they're watching it oh we're
having a good time it's all honest mud
come on it's 3:00 in the morning 4:00 in
the morning it's you know grab the good
time what else you gonna do right now
yeah sleep it's Tuesday night cuz he
could do that good go out
brush come on about my wookie bow caster
if it takes 73 damage to use stone to
success again listen I mean there's I
don't think there's any better we can
get at this games so uh so do you want
to switch over to tonight's of the old
NES is a Nintendo I you know what I
never had Nintendo I don't think there
was a Sega one I mean listen I'm so old
I remember the arcade games when he
gotten the thing and it was like kind of
like I don't remember tempest or it was
like white lines and it was like a
little bit like defender ER like crap I
can't look yeah we can't lose this game
is garbage
come on the Google Play makes wonderful
games it's gorgeous it's beautiful I
just I just mean I think it's our skills
were just too good at it we came in here
you're making it look easy we've never
played this game before but this could
be you you could walk in you can go hey
I'm gonna download Star Wars Galaxies of
heroes and be your own hero
what is the auto button do let's try it
my way I'm getting crushing oh oh oh it
just kills people for you Wow so then so
now instead of pressing two buttons I'm
gonna press one to win the game thank
you guys hi no equipment back there oh
man hey thanks for that tidbit man yeah
you killed it it's great wait what's the
speed thing what we don't even have to
play what we don't even have to play
wait oh we ran out of autos now we
actually have to kill him I thing
okay oh I think I think something stuck
nothing pressing nothing's working at
all some of these comments I can't sale
nothing I can't say but they're
hilarious
you people are you guys are really funny
this is the most fun I've had a long
look at this incredible battle play out
behind this Wow Wow he's he's in it he's
getting sliced and diced look at that Oh
pasta
I've been foiled they ruined me they
really blew your cover
I feel like Vanna White now wait oh yeah
there we go
oh look we unlocked we may now view the
newsletter there's a nice letter what
letter won the Death Star that we can
read should we read the newsletter
unbelievable let me get this straight
we have rewards back when I was back
when I was y'all's age we used to play
video games with controllers and you
know there were other people and
involved skill and playing those people
and you know it's it's very it's
everything is down to the a nanosecond
with split hair-trigger decisions but in
this game it has an auto button you
press and it plays a game for you this
is why millenials are getting a bad rap
thank you
my generation cuz I'm in my twenties
there's dog hair Elena's there's dog
hair all over this couch just couches by
the way Union it's rented it's a union
couch and I'm not even kidding when I
say that
this is a union couch there's ours my
own time did not invent couches he
didn't invent couches but he did admit
cue cards man I have so much hair in my
mouth
Oh google play couch I like that idea
where's the guy that said pubes earlier
oh man oh yeah they're taking the robe
they love the grotto play video games in
a row right yeah one here's what I want
to do let's turn off all the lights and
just get a black light and then look at
the road just play Star Wars for Sarina
it's cool and has kylo Ren do we have
for Sarina see what schooi is should we
keep playing what do you guys want to do
you got more carats got more carats the
dog eats again so we just feed my dog
carrots playing video games that's still
republic all right let's do that
can we put cams or do you guys want to
keep playing this one
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
keep trying buddy I'm fine fine oh I
think we after we have to cut away naps
Oh two minutes we have all right let's
go guys next you know no it was not
meant week we got it we got it we got a
piece out and you could say that anymore
I don't uh we gotta get out of here in
about two minutes but guess what if they
actually eat the Conan gum I don't know
let's see oh here it is
or did I are we gonna split it yeah I
need any more chia seeds after that um
we're back to next hour right
okay guys guess what they just gave us
an additional hour our show got picked
up for an additional Oh what an extra
hour our unseen Hollywood most shows get
canceled do we get one of those like
little special things that happens like
ABC special that happens to have in the
80s Oh
to celebrate oh wait we gotta hide the
label though Oh daddy
apple-cider we're gonna have for the
second hour this bottle I can't do you
want to do the honors
yeah okay oh you gotta do this for are
you gonna know this is a twist
wait now they have twisty champagne
bottle this is just more millennial this
is Melina
don't you guys do anything yourselves
come on their aim it right in my eye
wait wait no wait
twist pop and reseal you might lose it I
am I I don't understand the Millennial
champagne bottles wait wait wait I got
it
Google Play champagne
oh nice
yeah Hazen seconds to celebrate our
second 32nd season under Ernest on the
team cocoa Google Play 24-hour mobile
marathon
brought to you by carats and Jake the
puggle we're going to the top of the
hour no Tommy the our message from the
man himself Conan O'Brien oh yeah we
yeah a man who writes the checks right
what's that there's a secret message
Makonnen but when is it coming in right
now
oh I'm just getting my ear piece you
know Jimmy he really as well can I go to
you Jake in that you're gonna gin with
the tape from Conan okay we're are gonna
take turn secret X's special message
from okay it's one o'clock which begs
the question what are you doing what I
go to bed are you getting sleepy I bet
you're getting sleepy you know at least
you're home I'm guessing you're home
that's that's an old thing to say well
if you're on your computer you must be
home I completely forgot you could be on
a mobile device huh stupid Conan right
I'm like well they're probably just
watch their Atari and their local news
and now they're on their computer well
you could be anywhere I just hope you're
staying safe stay safe out there be kind
rewind Tupac one o'clock stay
Zeon hey Jake Jake's hosting the show
gigs hosting the show huh I guess Jake
here I just wanted to let you know that
this is the team cocoa Google play's
24-hour mobile marathon all right we're
back pause good job Jake nice job Jay
was he he was probably the best host of
all well how many hours season two of
the Kent narak Team Coco Google play's
24-hour marathon continues for you just
tuning in we're cue card guys on the
corner Brian show we right cue cards
that's what we do that's what they ask
us that when we sleep with stuffed
animals we brought up org since its Star
Wars day on the show look at that little
Empire everyone agrees in by Cramer
where's the buyer the Kramer's leaving
are you guys late at night don't leave
us
hey Internet everybody say bye to Kramer
cram is taken up by yeah Oh get in here
Oh leave us alone miss a lot why are you
here let him watch that was fun we have
fun here at the best time I've had in a
while
yeah we do your faces are so red what's
so hot in here there's a bad idea you
know why it's hot is cuz you two are
sitting here
stop politeness is good talent it's our
synergy synergy
it's our hot burning landing not top
down syndrome bottom up so everyone says
bye on the internet cry Kramer
good night Kramer
why does Kona need to cue card guys
funny story
there's actually three of us okay we got
ports pornography Jake Jake I know Jake
I sleep at Kats house all the time and
Jake is row between me and Kent the
majority of that time so we should play
again how do I go to Star Wars Knights
of the Old Republic is that an option
yes I mean this is season two of our of
our stream here they said four seasons
here they want you to kill off road guy
whoa
it just might happen it's not Ken Ken's
kids with two team with two T's and
after tonight I'm gonna add a third team
since we can't just changed oh yeah
where's third guy News and why is
Chandler Bing wearing a bathroom
he gets that whoa tell them the story
about when you were in Minnesota doing
grumpy or oh these they don't know no
those people are they oh well just all
right they don't you know Internet does
anybody know what grumpy old man or
grumpy old men is these movies no do you
know who Walter Matthau is any worse no
these people are in Antarctica and
Istanbul they don't know and they're
like I know grumpy old men yes yes no
yes we know yes yes Walter Matthau yes
Jack Lemmon yeah okay look everybody
knows okay yeah look at that
you are wrong we see we've you know all
right all right I'll tell the quick
Stewart's a quick story always the game
know we get the game going so I was
working on that movie in Minnesota and I
went out to a dinner like a nice fancy
dinner with dude I'm 40 right on well
not to dinner with the cast so it was
like Jack Lemmon Walter Matthau my foot
sir and then from all the names he's
dropped I know I know
Daryl Hannah but burgess Meredith and
Margaret's you know all these like you
know great wonderful icons and me stupid
me right so the way at the end of the
meal though all the waiters the the
waitstaff was over in the corner
giggling and you know and huddling and
saying stuff and finally one of them got
to get up the nerve to come over and
Kevin Pollak yeah and one of them got
the nerve to come over and walked up to
me at the table and said I'm so sorry to
bother you but can I have your autograph
and it was like a record scratch so all
of a sudden the whole table looks at me
and like Walter Matthau
Walter Matthau and his looks at me he
goes it gives me this look like what are
you gonna do man and I said sure yeah
give you my autograph but why do you
want my why do you want my autograph and
she said well aren't you Chandler Bing
hi oh and I said I said no no I wasn't I
wasn't and so she left and she cried and
then everyone hated me after that and
didn't talk to me for the whole rest of
the shoot they want to know it's not
true but Jack Lemmon and Walter Matthau
for those two weeks came up to me every
day and asked me for my autograph so
that was cool and he wasn't holding cue
cards or either of them it was for
burgess meredith burgess meredith yeah
legend wonderful actor great guy see and
you know how I know his story as well as
he does because he tells it all of it
every day I at least tell it once a day
sometimes twice if I have enough energy
also I'll tell it three more times
before this don't worry though this guy
spelt my name with three ends and
forties nice
[Music]
ooh now they're talking about
masturbation I don't know the Internet
is a string I don't think we're allowed
to do that place yeah
Scott wants me to show my boobs here we
go oh my boobs dude come on
so now we're playing mm-hmm I mean maybe
if you want to see him Knights of the
Republic somebody said I want a cue
cards I want a career in cue cards well
[Music]
yeah yeah go to school go to school go
to school stay in school
H we call this Kent and Eric great show
[Music]
you got it I've never seen it but I've
heard that I think this is we should
call it a kid Jake the Jake the Jake
show Kent looks like a rotting melon
okay so that guy knows about that what
breed is this penguin hello from Holland
what's the best cue card school
kindergarten I've said that before kids
are in a class that's probably where you
start to learn how to do cue cards
here's I'll show you guys quickly it
well this thing plays out cue cards
everything's in capital letters right so
that's a small cute garden bay cue card
are you reading the opening crawl to
this game seven lines per card usually
right seven lines Kent in caps Jenna
conan's and black
andis in dark blue ink and a desperate
and everybody else is any other green or
red y'all play you wanna talk yeah well
okay there you put the poor great here
help out this it's hammerhead Corvette I
don't need to have that you a person may
have to do better you guys know that you
don't need to have good penmanship to do
cue cards it's pretty much muscle memory
all you have to do is like trainee
wrists to write capital letters all the
way across the card fun part for me
please write with left hand you know if
you are left-handed you can do cue cards
we do have people that do cue cards and
you know when your ride usually smears I
have to [ __ ] your wrists up a little bit
right left-handed I know several people
that Duke yards Wally
Ferris Dean who is the lead cue card guy
at SNL you'll see him from time to time
he's a left-handed cue card guy
[Music]
and he does other stuff left-handed too
they know what I'm talking about
dip into our pockets no oh it says
French bye you guys
we've been ambushed by a sit battle
fleet the end of spires so did I look
for a Gary up we don't have much time on
Craigslist no here's the weird thing
about late I'll tell you right off the
bat about late night yeah I'm just gonna
knock everything out of the everybody's
asking how do you get a job in late
night television how do you do honestly
either know somebody or you intern and
you do a great job but a job in late
night television is it's like a Senate
run nobody ever leaves they know because
we're the only like show that shoots
year-round and that's honestly renewed
all the time you know like late-night
shows usually do people want to know
this should I stop talking about it I
will we'll just play the games must be
boy probably bored I'm kidding it was a
great story Eric you're the best
Chewbacca impression good Oh
that's pretty good
that this is a female Wookiee it's a
female Wookiee a little more
high-pitched okay let's go help Bastilla
people are saying doc if they want cone
and no one cares about us they keep
asking more Conan is get soda and Coney
it sounds like a dying bird he's he's
asleep right now he's in bed he's
actually snot no he's he's sleeping on a
couch upstairs
he's probably we're gonna cut to them
later we tap him with the stick and then
we wake him up and then he does his
livestream don't have a poke Conan with
a stick see that what it might happen no
he's actually probably laying in bed
with his wife right now with his guitar
playing can't find my way home by blind
faith or a place plays a lot of the same
songs every day
can I in robe you look like you're
getting a prostate exam but down here
you come down here I'll give you a free
prostate exam all is whatever you want
does anybody need one rear us takes
exams for anybody in the room Jake the
puggle said he needs me well sir which
cake that's gonna be in the second half
stay tuned for a tautology exam
prepare my catheter
no they move the catheter we use it they
want goes who's all in the background
it's all the ladies that run he's yeah
oh yeah I should come over here cuz
Hannah's dressed like a pug put your put
your head up your head up and grab Jake
and comes to the gym are we have we
played any of this I'm getting there
okay we keep talking to people
I feel like we're not doing a service
you're the team coat go at something
Google plays this 24-hour mobile
marathon Lane here's Hanna look at me
give it up everybody good Hanna is
dressed like a pug and not only that
didn't know I was bringing in a plug
goal this is pug the gas we have app org
puggle and a pug all together dream team
that is a that is a the letter P
alliteration or G if you will
sorry tonight's a orgy no no no sorry
FAA
all right thanks Hanna Hanna so cute
that was fun how many cups of coffee
have been consumed in the making of this
stream oh just just three glasses of
chia seeds you know I've have I honestly
I'm on no no that's the hemp seeds and
that one no no no I'm actually I'm a
little low on the cheese can I get a few
more chia seeds I mean dude how long do
you have to talk to these people let's
just play let's play
it's like a whole no man no no no some
people are asking am I putting this
stuffed animal in a certain area in your
but don't do that don't do what the
internet tells you to do that I just
wish I learned that the part I want to
show you one more such my pants that's
what I'm learning tonight I wore too
tight of pants I shouldn't have done it
worn a robe man that's that's Jane it is
hey it's the 20th anniversary of The Big
Lebowski today really there we go oh man
I bring it all together perfect perfect
thank you for that Diamond Dallas Page
Oh Oh you swipe up with two fingers to
move that's what she said wait okay
okay see these two fingers don't get it
I don't get it either grow up okay
everybody wants me to go to the Foot
Locker sure it's a little trick when
you're cheetahs have a little bit too
much Chia
take a little face crease you put it in
there and guess what no more Chia so you
[ __ ] you're not playing this on a pc I
don't know man this is here to have a
good time play some games enjoy life
do you guys smoke weed during work
what's weed thirty-year-olds act now
come on where's the restroom what is
wrong Dan your hi Eric I'm high on life
PC all the way I agree but do you know
it's sometimes you're gonna switch it up
a little a good time playing
we're just playing games like a good
honest cancellous I feel like this is
like a good slumber party and
everybody's invited
yeah I propose that we just cut these
games out we just played our toes off
what what I said playing a girl talk oh
yeah let's do that okay wait we took our
clothes how would you that okay
I'm not gonna he might take his place
have you touched Conan before will you
touch him
I miss the topper how touch how I've
touched his heart Oh cute
no I've never met the man I'm not gonna
be I'm not gonna like ya none of us have
ever met we've never met him it's done
side note side story has a hyperbolic
chamber that he stays in until the show
somebody has said how many emails from
HR is Kent going to get tomorrow that's
a question we ask every day every day at
the show people go close it HR aware of
Kent what's a charm oh the tick sucker
you see that means I hit a home run run
yeah buddy an RBI
you're never striking out here alright
well you know I'd love to get out of
this room I've been to the same room
yeah you need to walk man what the doors
locked already went to the locker room
help me out internet what do i do does
any anybody you're hoping to show you
I'm gonna show you how to get out wait
[Music]
do I get to keep my dignity in the
meantime here he comes
ahh how did Conan get in the game that's
amazing that's so cool wait so I should
follow Conan whoa
Conan how did you get in the game it's
like all my fantasies have come true
this is like this is what my dreams are
like every night
[Music]
Coenen is directing me to the vault all
right where's the balls balls balls
balls that's not a ball that's not a
ball talking to me hey dude where's the
balls so everybody say Conan
do I miss your gear on did I miss going
22 wait what did I miss Conan yeah oh
geez comes out watching this is asleep
no I heard he'd stop by wait hold on
hold on
I got a text it's me Conan I'm watching
and you're fired
not again can't we did it again
well looks like they're just gonna have
to go and do what everybody's been
saying online they're gonna have to go
to the prompter the third time they've
been fired
where's the vault put on your gear come
on come on okay I'm gonna quit my stuff
here here's a question people would you
like to see us you could put implants
talk more or move from Star Wars Knights
of the Republic to Monument Valley
[Music]
you see this was supposed to be the
Eiffel Tower that's what I was going for
there and then a valley you see if you
live in the valley in Los Angeles it's
got a bad rap God background can I both
live in the valley right
I love the valley I love the belt I like
it's a bad rap but Ally gets a bad rap
for no reason at all and we're not just
talking about cardi B it's out the girls
oh the kids listen to cardi B can you
solve your calculus problem
screw you we can't say the other one
right now somebody lives next the Eiffel
Tower and you love my representation
because this is identical
that's an identical picture of the
Eiffel Tower right right Monument Valley
Trask has joined your party wait what
does that mean oh there are other people
in here playing with me no cue card
artists can't draw now we can but we can
write letters and get paid for itself
joke's on you all right no more start
over look at how weird and funky this
guy is he's wearing a tower team
consumers are tedious ok did that I
shouldn't I was telling that
I see okay see we have a bunch of stuff
on the floor it says this ignore
negative comments from chat how long
have you worked at coding see these are
talking points they want us to head what
is your job title what does it entail
day today how did you get your job
Star Wars is not a snooze fest dude come
on man
it's so exciting go watch some parsecs
back again it's pretty much a perfect so
Kent what does it entail oh I have some
Star Wars trivia to do you know dude
that your shirt Empire Strikes Back yeah
there's a scene by Armstrong
there's a scene in the start and I did
not write the ones on the floor those
are crabs I'm kidding no one does you
need violation you're telling a story
I was yeah you're telling a story about
Oh Empire Strikes Back trivia know what
it doesn't seem like it I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna say it anyways in case someone
you know isn't um right after at the
beginning after the Battle of Hoth and
the the rebels escape and the last
transport gets away and there's someone
that says the last transport is away the
last transport is away and everyone
cheers that who's the guy who did the
voiceover for that Mark Hamill who
played Luke Skywalker
okay okay well that was a moment
calculus yeah hmm hey make sure you guys
guys get your taxes in before April 17th
that's the day we're planning a game
yeah we're playing a new game
oh yeah April 17th guys I don't know
what it's like in other countries but uh
you know that's the guy in Antarctica
okay there's a building this is called
um just know it's a Knights in that
night I know it's Knights with a cave I
don't know how to do this I'm hitting
buttons I don't hear you try that's
chatroom should I be looking at the
Twitter wait wait wait wait wait wait
go ahead
Star Wars is cancer oh there's always
cancer come on it's fun what did
somebody say oh yeah we're leaving now
we're loaded oh okay look can't see he
wants you to lick my ear who chugged oh
yeah where's the champagne
[Music]
your breath smells like syphilis mm-hmm
can we say syphilis no no that's not
sponsored the nra is gonna be after me
after that I think they want to sign us
after this show oh good good
no bring Hannah back and make her eat
cheese Hannah they love you you're a
huge hit yep cheese we have cheese right
that was weird
oh she can't have cheese past 1 a.m.
it's like a gremlins thing
how do our egg wash is does anybody know
it's not racist you can say someone's
half Mogwai the internet is crazy things
are weird
Oh someone just fired me again you got
away yeah I think I got funny-looking
ironing wait okay there's three chat
things up this is too much chat
happening at one yeah if you guys can
all coordinate between the chats like
will be like that one goes then this one
syphilis we have a YouTube yeah that was
good another Twitter is that twitch chat
and then we have a Facebook so alright
so syphilis syphilis meh no syphilis man
it sounds like a server scary it is well
this song goddess it is the dark side oh
yeah but he said it's syphilis or UN
syphilis oh I do stead of syphilis the
internet said word to the wise
somebody's from Poland nice to meet you
monument valley rules Regas a romantic
monument valley yes I'm trying to get in
I don't know oh well the game replied
yes I think I accept I don't know what
it makes up then continue oh no thanks
oh wait no I'm probably putting on bets
continue Oh porn oh no we just have a
beautiful ideas and so I'm gonna help me
just have a gorgeous casa I'm gonna help
me they can't see the game I just need
to figure out how to get the monument
Jake oh they're calling for Jake Jake
they're calling for you
come on I got a carrot for you buddy
should we instead of eating that on my
mouth you want to eat it out of my buns
this time here we go how can we do that
yeah all right here we go are your
parents proud of you sitting on a couch
and talking over each other and nothing
and doing nothing beneficial for human
society my parents are very proud of me
honestly they call them all the time
they're like get them the hell out of
here
my parents are actually the ones any
negative comment you see those are my
parents that's fine Oh
ummso daintily I'll tell you what we are
contributing Society 102 wait I'm doing
it bound is that America who sang that
who can we get a shoes am we'll do it
again will shoes they emit guy said 103
oh this is the game I'm like tapping
around this is the game 103 dumbass is
this literally the game now do you like
lasagna oh yeah this is literally the
game I don't know what no I think we
should retry oh it was like it's 103
dumbass
it's all frozen under my knees whoa BAM
better damn that's some sticks you guys
you've probably never heard of them we
got just got called boring and old first
thing I've agreed exactly I get it
that's actually the name of the
sandwiches first record that's right
that's my boring and old no Jake's old
he's 11 he's going on 12 so he's not
gonna be around very much longer so 12
and puggles only we're supposed to live
to 10 so this game is like look at this
game there's like stairs I'm supposed em
hold and rotate that's what I do net
every night that didn't make sense
am i did my foreigner
somebody said turn star wars offered
this know it's like Jacob blocks with
like some weird Ku Klux Klan member with
the little pointy everyone knows stick
saying Africa come on you want to try
this team cocoa Google plays 24-hour
normal marathon coming at you we have 30
minutes to kill Kent I mean they think
we can't do it but I'll tell you what
bro you just gotta hold and rotate
hold and rotate I'm not talking about
the game
wait no one's really watching there's
the millet I feel like I feel like this
is the cable access in 1987 let's get a
fun background back here let's change
this up let's get some gravy going the
guy's a total idiot somebody might know
Toto sing Africa man the Internet is
just some interesting Google Play
sponsored this yeah
I'm currently I know it's simplest
enough syphilis the other guy says
syphilis it's a joke come on Internet
Jake just mind-control them they are all
puppets me cue Zito they're all you get
it
Mickey Ozzie - all right we're going
back to the cards I mean come on I mean
we don't need oh brats or what are these
brats all right
we're gonna go get some brats right side
two just brought sausages
yeah Africa by toto it's a great song
all right somebody's gonna get a game
going for us in the meantime we're gonna
hang out with Brad sausages we promote
stuff over here no no no this is all
about Google plays 24-hour morbol
marathon sponsored by to sponsor my
Google Play Team Coco I wanted to give a
plug for my buddy's company it's Johnson
catheters for young dogs oh that's a
that's a good cause I actually didn't
think you were gonna bring it up tonight
but I'm excited to hear about the own to
do I do you wanted me to do a little
demonstration do you have a dog that's
in a coma
yeah but need the catheter thing do you
want to be plausible
do the intolerance Anna do you need a
cabbage more ken it's not candidates Ken
it's kids like the night walking with
like 19 teens at this point with the
teeth how many T's am I gonna add before
you call me Kent sorry
do you do I didn't what and what else we
got are we here to play video games
oh why are am i on acid oh we're playing
good even in the background can we go
back to the store I mean at least it's a
Star Wars game we had some music going I
mean no we can't say that word you guys
are yeah that's dirty you're dirty
alright I think should we talk more
about your job on the show which job
oh what's your job thank you our job
okay yeah so cat what time do you roll
into work in the morning uh it depends
man it depends on what I mean for
breakfast like if I have one of those
you know omelets or I'm just like Oh
dill would be good Matt and I you know
just keep adding stuff and all of a
sudden there's like 39 things in my
omelet then maybe I'll be there around
eleven twelve eleven thirteen 112 what
time's the production meeting that code
yeah what time we get out of work you
know time is just a constraint that I
don't adhere to you know I like to live
fluidly I'd like to remind everybody
can't spend to 160 fish shows and this
is actual fact is not embellished get
has been to 160 fishing more than that
now it'll be a lot more than that to
summer especially after the festival you
guys gonna come with me to the fish
festival oh my goodness somebody asks
again why cue cards instead of
teleprompters I'll explain right now
okay so Kent but you can't move a
teleprompter period that's it so here's
a cute card new cars one right above
Kanza
watch you can move it can't a camera
can't sack and if I'm talking to
somebody and also I gotta look over the
magazine's over
look look look good so now I'm in
another line that's behind Ken if you
watch days of your life I'm talking to
you right now now look at this but now I
got a line though I gotta see it over oh
yeah you gotta say it over here wait but
the teleprompter is still a tie but if
you're dead why isn't it moving I don't
know wait let's see what I'm supposed to
say what what are you gonna say yeah
where are you gonna look oh here we are
but we are robots I'm not gonna lie to
you this hand that cut it off they turn
into a machine much like the Star Wars
game which is part of the team cocoa
Google play's 24-hour mobile marathon
sponsored by Google plays be ain't
playin you ain't winnin and if you ain't
winnin you ain't tried and if you ain't
tryin good luck Google Phil gates I'm
just saying words now that's all I'll do
it I'm just saying words oh don't ever
eat a carrot with gum in your mouth I
wouldn't do it don't ya that's still
Conan's gum yeah yeah like I coughed it
back up so somebody had to come never
stop she did it who's done
why don't you play
I don't even get this when he has enough
air Conan in Italy one time when it's
koto and 80 rolls in April with Jordan
Chilean ski everybody wants to have a
Jordan story do we have Jordan stories
I'm Jordans a nice guy hey I bet it is I
love Jordan he's super fun how well you
know one thing about about a super fun I
will say the one he's about Jordan
Jordans minutes honest with anybody that
works on the staff but Jordan you go
anywhere and you say that you work on
Conan they could be a minor fan of the
show or a huge fan of the show they
always go who's that guy you work with
and easy like that and then you remind
him of the name and he goes it's Jordan
everybody loves it so you're gonna have
a whole special Jordan Italy Kent's
currently shredding his his Jordan in a
relationship yes Jordan is married and
he has a child on the way
[Music]
oh I'm in the sea now
[Music]
whoa I'm blending into the ocean I
didn't work as good as I thought it
would
I'm blending into the ocean kind of
hey buddy welcome welcome to our cable
access show
havin a good time but actually the
creature sorry
don't worry about the pants which is how
I swim I'm a starfish wait we could
create a surface for girls yeah yeah
it's just know our Terms put your ass to
adjust our I know you got together oh
wait let me get in front of you because
I don't go through me look how cool that
looks
has anyone done this yet tonight no no
nobody thought about this that's awesome
dude it's like a floating head floating
arm
that's exciting what what what all right
all right more games
everybody's bagging forward play some
more video games that was tattooed are
you turning to look at the hide this is
the floating head now I'm just a
floating head that's great a couple arms
can you sing once I've done that it's
fun legally we can't afford once in
lifetime yeah that's all I got
this guy thanks for hi come on
[Music]
we'll never get over that
all right now I'm walking I'm walking
yes I did something all right we're
moving forward he misses the ropes guys
he's still talking this guy
somebody says you guys will get fired
soon why
where's Pierre Bernard Kendrick starfish
we come up with nicknames Kent can we
play games on your chest that's not a
bad idea we do that it's somebody else
how old I know how old are we
well I would like to say this I'm a LA
23 age is just a concept of time you
guys doesn't mean anything likes to tell
the joke it's like I'm I mean I'm eating
out at 51 you're in LA actor and I yes
how old they are
I'm very strong years old I'm one year
younger than I was the year before I'm
13 years one of those I'm 30 years old
his mom I'm 30 are you really I'm 30 Wow
man you look good
thanks man yeah old are you I am 74
[Music]
delicate that's crazy
creams and ointments kids you know what
that's always your ice creams and
ointments what was Jesus like I don't
have a zipper yeah those are down
because he could consider those in
separate Kent's already receiving
double-double ARP pamphlets in the menu
well the internet the Internet is a
crazy place isn't it besides there it's
funny man I mean Bailey are like uh sir
they ate us I guess that's just the way
it goes sometimes
hmm dude I love that I'm just a floating
head this is the best idea yet yeah I
don't have any boobs to hold on to dopes
oh yeah oh there's hard more about cards
do I think phantom thread was robbed at
the Oscars that's something I keep
saying okay and we're gonna keep doing
tasks are you still talking to the same
guy I talked to this guy like an hour
ago with the same conversation here give
me that I've been looking at this tablet
for the last 45 minutes I would say I
got it I can't
regular people time you know but time is
just a construct you know thank you
someone finally agrees with me look
there's utility joy see now we're
getting somewhere
it's a great game I can't believe this
is all somebody said Kent so old he hit
on Maude Adams Adam why do you think I'm
so old
because I know Africa by toto he that he
was a personal friend of Walter Matthau
okay is that why okay that is that why
then he worked under up your old men and
let's equal the fact that Bob Hope in
him I was a set decorator in Casablanca
also which was shot I'm a Warner
Brothers lot which we are currently on
oh really fun a little tidbit is on our
stage they shot The Goonies
The Goonies shoot in the same they also
should have copied on ghostbusters they
also shot ghostbusters on the stage what
they did yes they shot ghostbusters one
two or 12 all of them really
yes everyone I think I think a third of
that is accurate that's great
hey you guys I let your company no that
was law Oh cuz no the electric company
is more about work dudes so these are
small pens which you use for the smaller
cards you see they're not a there's no
company name involved but this is what a
yes hey who's played this before why
didn't they come in several colors they
come in blue but it can play in the
common black man you know they don't
come in white as da graça but every
single person is spelling my name with
12 ends and 40 tees
that's hilarious Kent never watch Bob
Ross and go hey that's my job
uh-huh I love Bob Ross yeah sometimes we
just hang out you go I'm just gonna make
some pretty little and letters and I'm
gonna make some beautiful little cute
you over here yeah I'm gonna put a
underline that's a little squiggly
mm-hmm you know mm-hmm there aren't any
mistakes you know there's are leaner
snakes there's only happy accidents
right that's right
[Laughter]
[Music]
what does everyone think I'm so old but
why are you getting so upset about oh
I'm good it's shocking how many comments
you know Kent you're I need come on okay
I'm gonna get it don't know whether
you're not saying there's nothing wrong
with being old I get it I'm there like a
nicely aged steak okay
you taste delicious I like steaks you
got a good inside I don't know I didn't
know where I was going
no no go on tasty insides
no more tasty inside you know I didn't
know the door's locked
I said somebody said Kate you're so old
when you saw rainbows there a
black-and-white Internet is so mean come
on Internet you look like you were
twenty five eighty years ago
[Laughter]
[Music]
gosh
Internet you're hilarious keep playing
this no 1500 viewers that's a good call
we're on let's twitch they're calling us
the Internet twitch we're at you we see
we got 1500 of you we appreciate you
thank you so much for watching thanks
for saying you are 1,500 strong in your
commenting and you're killing it and we
love you and thank you so much for
tuning in to the team cocoa Google plays
24-hour mobile marathon sponsored by
Google Play that's what we're doing
we're playing with Google no I'm not
wearing a green shirt I just have a head
and arms
no no torso no tours yeah
God made me okay yeah problem with that
take it up with HR geez label alone was
the Gettysburg Address as good as they
say kid didn't have a calculator in
school he had an abacus
guys he's trust me guys he's playing it
off cool he doesn't care
that's fine I'll stop myself to sleep
tonight did Boathouse skip work tonight
I'm gonna get Botox somebody said can we
see your camera crews yeah if you go to
the local bar in Burbank you could
probably find me
there they are spirit boys yeah it's
good stuff
what just a pair of hands pair arms and
heads you guys who is the coolest guest
on the show
I mean coated gave great you know praise
to Kevin Hart when he was just on the
show
Kevin Hart's great my favorite my
personal favorite is Jeff Goldblum my
personal favorite is Norma Donald norm
is great he's so funny he goes off his
rocker and he's just Conan just goes
with it who do we have today can we say
hey are we allowed to what do we love
yeah
no no no not the cobbler Oh Martin Short
another one up yeah my shirt was
ride-along believe it bill burr
unbelievable guess Tom Hanks when we can
get him
unbelievable guests it's great oh what a
genuinely nice guy
sweet hearts just fills my heart with
love gives hugs he's amazing I'll tell a
story about it yes
ooh Steve Martin was on the show and he
was the musical guest and the guests on
the couch legend a legend great
Bloody Mary Steve Martin and I thought
the coolest thing about Steve Martin was
he was the guest on the show and he was
a musical guest and when the show ended
I was walking out of the back of the
studio and Steve Martin was gigging his
own equipment into his own minivan to go
home
and if you're a musician you know that
like usually big musicians come through
and you have people that do that for you
Steve Martin gigs himself and that shows
that little is he hilarious but he's a
great person in G I mean legends yeah
he's the best
wrote clean shoes
one of the funniest books you'll ever
read write cruel shoes it's another one
it's a what's the bride when he was in
father the mother of the bride so if you
go up then to the to the Greek Theatre
you walk by that house hold on but the
good what is new so are you actually
playing the game well I was in the go
through this guy's remains there's a car
in it I got a grab Jake I mean he has to
make it appear before our episode and
then dig through this guy's remains guys
I don't think we were picked up for
season 3 but I feel bad taking stuff out
of this guy's pockets when he's dead but
that's what they want you to do in the
go that doesn't teach children good
things does it we were picked up for
season 3 Oh how did you turn my chroma
key down my ogre I'm not Joe man I
should I go put the robe back on or just
take your shirt off I think that's what
America wants no I know I just wanted to
see a floating head okay can't you
witness Lincoln's assassination what was
that like are they still talking about
how old I am guys they are they're not
leaving let it go Internet no I'm 26 I'm
14 I'm 14 years old if he's 26 I'm
fortunate
[Music]
I'm pretty anyways I think we're we're
gonna crawl down this hallway for last
10 minutes I'm just gonna run I'm gonna
see how long I can run for it I'm gonna
run into things okay cool
wasn't this a game where you could just
like won over stuff and he just ran as
quick as he could yeah did you play that
one for a while
he's got dainty he tried to take it 26
times 250 - somebody said 26 might but
they don't believe you can okay one way
to prove it prove it put your ID on the
screen get your Social Security card
let's let everybody verify it put your
credit card up there let's show the
three numbers on the back and let's just
verify your information for everybody in
America I'll put my social security
check up there and show you wait no way
not back on the internet once it's on
there it's on for life
Kent did you eat what is a child lettuce
yes yes yes
- what oh we up we have five minutes we
only have five minutes we have five
minutes left everybody so I guess we got
to say thank you to YouTube thank you to
twitch thank you to Facebook thank you
to everybody on here and get a Google
plate is Google Play one there's so fun
it makes me want to go get a light
singing mirror I'm running into a dark
I'm just ready to go look at this I go
I'm gonna buy all these games me too I
already got him when I just want put my
robe on I downloaded all
there's so much fun Jake already owns
them in his head
I mean he's telepathic I definitely will
hang this over about front - you're on a
plane you can download these games you
can play them on a plane you can
download them iOS Android words yeah
hashtag oh yeah he said your social
security number his school but dude
that's coming of the night whoever wrote
that please do it again I'll write you
numbers early bands I am the social
security card won over you I will I will
amazing right you a personal cute card
you guys are jerks come on so thank you
guys so much thank you - this is it
Google place 24-hour mobile marathon
yeah these guys are crushing it man this
has been so much fun
we are ready it's still going on till
noon tomorrow
we got Jemma we're just got to go to bed
because we got to work tomorrow we got
to work in the morning huh shut him out
shout who out everybody that's working
tonight yeah everybody they're crushing
it this isn't so fun the studio Lanisha
yes everyone let's just start from the
top let's start from the top let's go
around the road team Coco and we gonna
think let's just do like a little our
Molinari let's both do a Oscar speech
okay all right you start first I would
like to thank Jake if it weren't for you
eating carrots out of my mouth I think
this would have been a really less fun
two hours I would like to thank Eric who
has really made this what it is none of
us would be here Thor
I certainly wouldn't I would have
wandered off a long time ago who knows
where I'd be I'd be in a bathroom on
stage 48 over a Big Bang Theory waking
up in the morning not having clue where
I was if it weren't for Eric he's done a
great job tonight I'm not taking off the
robe but as you can see I'm starting to
get a little pee kid you can always see
through me but you guys look great
there's been a lot of fun except for all
the old jokes
it has not been cool but you know
whatever we forget forget we have a good
time it was like I'd like to give it up
to Google Play yeah like give a team
Coco
every day on YouTube everybody on
Facebook that's following along everyone
else working in the studio love that the
boy Jake Jake Jake my baby boy - hey
Jake Jake Jake yeah this is just this is
a group hug this no we leave
he'll the love internet it's all love
internet spread some love instead of
saying I want to say mean old jokes you
know you want to work on a show like
this don't think you can't don't think
me kill think you can't don't think you
can you can everything that's the
biggest question I've been watching this
stream before anything out here today
and people want to know how do you work
at the show find a way to get your foot
in the door kick it down you never know
where you gonna land but keep on going
the earth syphilis thanks okay all right
I'm gonna read a cue card oh there's
cute irony and then there's Lou cards so
cue card and blue card are different all
right how are they different Eric well
just kidding I don't care go ahead I got
three minutes all right okay okay this
is this is the end of season two of
kenton Eric and Jake we love everybody
yeah we had a good time thank you for
having us you can find us on the
internet somehow you'll find us you
can't find we can't say it up here
because this isn't about us it's about
Google Google Play and cocoa and sort of
it but look for us you'll find us twitch
and YouTube and guess what Erin's not
dead Erin will come back at some point
okay you get where's blaze easy I've
seen a while I have to write I have to
read um excuse me it's taking a poop
okay it's the top of the hour let's
check in with coding okay
two o'clock I'm keeping my body moving
so I don't get creepy I do that every
now and then I jump around I stretch I
move and that way I'm present for you
the people who were doing this thing and
two o'clock in the morning it's probably
pretty quiet where you are things get
real quiet spooky at two o'clock in the
morning
your weird noises and you realize those
are coming from your own intestines
anyway
move around if you need to drink some
water stretch two o'clock I'll see you
at 3:00 that's it for us up next are
coworkers
John Danny again from t2 that's it for
us
up next are coworkers
great enjoy enjoy party the digitally
enhanced birds from the last Jedi yeah
they were inspired by real birds I don't
know how we're supposed to follow that
that was that was like having to do your
first state upset after Eddie Murphy or
something yeah I know much less about
cue cards but I can make up stuff oh
here we go
so my name is John Dannic we work it
Team Coco Digital we're very excited to
be here on Team Coco Google Play 24-hour
mobile marathon is awesome hey everybody
let's see we got a YouTube on the right
we got a twitch
we got Facebook this is awesome
[Music]
Something About You Diana but this is a
childhood dream of mine to play video
games for work if I can go back in time
I would have specified the time of day
but you know what is fine is fine I
would like noon maybe 9:00 a.m. but hey
this works this works so I think the
first game we're starting here is punch
quest which is one that I'm quite
familiar with have you ever played this
it's very simple I think you should
start so once you hit start the game is
going to begin and your guy runs to the
right the entire time and this just you
just touch the two halves of the screen
to either jump or punch it's pretty
simple and you'll find that as you play
longer that you can make it farther each
level and then you kind of get abilities
and special moves and stuff and it is
quite a time waster and now you're
riding the dinosaur I took all of what
ten seconds is good yeah streak going
has anybody out here ever played the
punch quest I think it's one of the best
uh mobile games see hello from bazzill
hello Leonardo what's up I would love to
go to Brazil I've never been there
goodnight the rake I hope you pleasant
dreams
yes Omega it is an amazing game I agree
and I've spent a lot of hours playing it
on my couch it's something about the
simple games that just like a really
tactile like you feel like you're
punching somebody whenever you hit them
it just feels good it's so good yeah but
you made it to like what level eight on
your first time around
[Music]
yeah maybe something with some goals
here if we can defeat 20 enemies or
block three attacks or land some
overhead slam should I forget what that
is but we can do those things I think we
get some extra points and we can level
up over time so let's see you got twenty
three thousand eight hundred ten points
that sounds pretty good I don't know how
that it changes to American currency or
Bitcoin but you can find that out later
I have actually in that world and it's
not been great if you've been following
a past few weeks but you know what we're
here to play video games do not worry
about financial that's wise it's not
fine but it's okay we'll see let's see
good things could happen alright there's
there's 20 enemies right there we got a
gun little bonus going those skulls but
the tentacles are really creepy like
everything in this game is generally
pretty like cutesy but like those things
they kind of remind me of the Medusa
heads from Castlevania
we feel bit off they're like really evil
whereas the other things are just like
adorable
just like touching a zombie feels good
no matter what game it is
[Music]
and he got me he got me because I was
talking smack it doesn't play cleanser
[Music]
good call I have a huge misfits fan I
even like the graves era but I mean
obviously Danzig is classic what are
your favorite misfit songs out there
let's get a poll going I know what I
like which one and then the lyrics go to
a place that I probably yeah that is my
favorite song
you know whip that up on your own time
so let's see I think we got some extra
bonuses there I got I'm actually not
sure doesn't say I think you next it
might say oh yeah so I get to lovely
I've actually played this game like a
lot more than I care to admit but that's
kind of how it goes with uh with these
things let's see
hybrid moments classics all one of the
best
Hellena also great from the graves era I
see you guys do know the lyrics that
continue on that song good on you
speaking of music we played a band
together and we were called the Chang's
named after Diana Chang there five of us
and diana is the frontwoman clone myself
yeah the name of the band is the Chang's
as in Diana Chang you google us we're on
all the social networks Phil freed up a
new EP coming very soon we have a name
yet if you have any suggestions thrown
out we'll be looking for those can you
play some of your songs we don't have
any instruments here if we're doing
really poorly at these games if it goes
that way I guess that's an option
oh yeah there's awesome big screen up
here watch consider I was like watching
your tablet all time HDTV that's like
bigger than the one I have at home
there's a lot going on this one is
really cool this reminds me of like a
dorm party on a Wednesday night in
college when like nobody went out but
everybody just like stayed up the whole
night playing video games and it's like
starting at 2:00 a.m. because there's
just like paper everywhere and cups
knocked over and it's comfy the
chenggang the Chang and bangs see James
chained up that's pretty cool
is that a pun or would you call that a
fun it works yeah somebody said uh play
Galaga it just went off the screen and
actually I think most of the games we're
starting with like a 16-bit sound game
here but we're gonna play some older
games
I think Megaman and maybe our type might
be on there because everybody's been
playing like all the new cool stuff
we're gonna kick it old school for a
while
[Music]
oh that's great especially if we could
get you know an endorsement that's
always good you say hello from Tijuana
oh you're just neighbors from us come up
and see a taping sometime I am 138
another green misfit song what's the
name of the songs on the EP we just
switched up the chords gonna go on the
radio on the radio I have to know
third is long summer day and those first
three are Diana written songs and the
fourth one will be altercation with the
deer which uh it's one I wrote about a
college experience
yes Mega Man will be coming up at some
point hi Diana
from Tokyo oh we have years from Tokyo
[Music]
good time would it be in Tokyo I think
11 hours ahead of us yeah that's it I
was in Tokyo 2016 I absolutely loved it
and I hope to go back very soon it was
such a fun time we will be soon probably
in the coming weeks
so feel free to look out for that see
what does count and digital do do you
just upload to YouTube and post a
snapchat that is a great question we do
so many things and I can even run down
in this time but uh so my job title is
web developer so I actually oh you made
it far you made it to month oh 9 as well
goals nice I should feel proud I highly
disagree I think you boy you dominated
so many zombies and evil tentacle skulls
so I'm a web developer which a lot of
people are confused when I tell them
that that Conan O'Brien has web
developers but there are two of us I
mean there's only two of us then we
write the code for Team Coco calm the
apps the Android and iOS app and uh cool
thank you guys there's a lot of help
going on over here and everybody here is
very lovely and gracious and it's a it's
a fun time over here 24 hours yeah yeah
so they're starting those shifts take
shifts taking caps yeah it's madness
yeah so we have to software developers
if you ever ever seen Silicon Valley we
do what they do in that show we write
code for the website and the apps and
systems that we use internally and it's
a it's madness we do front-end when you
back in we do apps a lot of stuff yeah
we said let you sit back you back we see
each other a lot we're gonna band
together and we sit back to back at work
and we live like less than a mile apart
yeah we hang out all the time
you need coffee you need coffee you're
fine
we're here to power through just like us
so I work I do my outreach for the
website so for stuff like this like
tonight I emailed like all the blogs all
the video game blogs and the technology
bug and there was like one live
streaming blog
Oh tablet vlogs so anytime something
happens I think of like I've spent all
day you know like basically you know
like the entire Internet
so whatever anything happens with any
like specific fan community or like with
the sports world like you know where to
go for all that whatever random thing
gets discussed in like a guess interview
you have like a system of spreadsheets
that is impressive
thank you I I don't I don't understand
how they all work but I know you do I'm
the only person that's called job
security make sure nobody else
understands what and how you do and I
can't let you go yeah I was taught that
years ago and it works out pretty well
[Music]
we have our own custom CMS for the
website so our editors and our team
cocoa digital people will upload videos
through there and that's how they get
just distributed to all the various
platforms or you guys watch it on it's
pretty much everything is custom that
involves you guys watching it online it
probably starts through us in some way
shape or form
[Music]
pretty much yeah
we have an intern with us he's currently
learning the ropes so that's exciting
our first programming intern I did not
do very well and now we have Carol the
intern yeah thank you very much for
being here it's very much appreciated
hydrated yeah when you talk among the
developers are you doing modem noises
actually Diana can't attest to this
Travis tonight we don't speak that much
of verbally we talk a lot on our chat
thing because it's a lot of like copying
and pasting code and values and
different things so even if we start
talking verbally it ends up having to go
to that point at any point so let's see
it's really quiet
it is quiet it's peaceful people
actually from different parts of the
show come and hang out in our room
specifically because we have a couch and
they know it's a place of Zen peace and
I like we like to keep it that way what
game was that the punching one we're
playing currently playing punch quest on
the team cocoa Google Play 24-hour
mobile marathon and this is one of my
favorite games to play on my phone okay
so back to those Oscars yeah what did
you guys think about the Oscars
personally my favorite movie was not
nominated for anything I was a big fan
of mother which I know was divisive
amongst everybody I'm I've not met too
many people that loved it but that was
my favorite
[Music]
I think it was very very effective of
what it aimed to do and that was part of
that was to make you feel uncomfortable
and repulsed and think about the role of
humanity in the existence of Earth over
time just a lot of big concepts and also
just kind of relationships and life in
the creative world which we live there's
a lot of different concepts going on at
any one time in that movie and I really
like that but there is some crazy stuff
going on it's not a you should go again
somebody has to be dabbled in game
making a little bit in the show if if
you watch our website as we in the
previous years when we were heading to
comic-con we had a little kind of flash
style game on one of our splash pages
and I made that with the help of our
designers Atsuko Allison and B yeah it's
like it was like a running game kind of
like flappy bird or yell on those lines
and that was actually kind of a hey you
recovered
yeah that the little game project was a
kind of a nightmare because I learned a
valuable lesson and that is to read the
Terms of Service with whatever software
you use as I finished this project
realized a few days before we are about
to launch it that I didn't realize how
much we had to pay for it I thought we
were in the freeze here we were not so I
had to then build it all again from
scratch of open source stuff and it was
anger I was up until late a lot of
nights kind of like this night see I
think you have to buy some noobs see
what's your favorite guitar I'm a fan of
the Gibson SG for life and I also love
the Fender Jaguar that's my current
number 100 that's perfect how do you
realize their props around yeah little
size appropriate I think so
see somebody is asking in all caps do
you like Game of Thrones
do you watch Game of Thrones I have
never seen any you've seen everything
it's great and I always started going
back to watch the I watched all of them
and then as soon as like the season
finale last time when season one didn't
make any sense the first time around
they were hinting at things that happen
throughout the rest of the show I love
where shows do that I mean obviously not
aren't they like past where the books
are now so like they're kind of blazing
their own Trail I'm not too familiar
with that world despite all of my
friends telling me that I would love it
and I know that I probably would but
there we go these blue guys with the
spiked things are pretty intense again
once they get the shield's they're nuts
I think later they get spiked shields
but this is a very fun game it's super
addictive especially once you start
buying like the different upgrades and
qualities though I'm very close to die
here it's gonna happen any second oh I
only had half a of it gets harder the
farther you get but once you restart it
goes back to like the initial days
please please make a full Kona game that
would be awesome that would be awesome
that would be a ton of work in addition
to the normal work that we do but uh
it'd be really cool let's check facebook
did you guys record your EP on your own
yes we did we actually refer to most of
it in my bedroom like we used to have
before he got like the microphone that
has a wall behind it we used to like
just open up his closet you can like set
up the microphone
yeah just like singing to his clothes
yeah we're up creating a little bit so
if there are any uh amateur music
producers out there if you have nothing
but a basic microphone stick in your
closet those clothes absorb a lot of the
reflections of sound and you can get a
really good sound there it is very much
like a running version of Double Dragon
which is great I I love I'm partial to
old school games the only like modern
game that I play regularly is
counter-strike I don't know if we've
ever done on stream Coco or not but that
can maybe be a cool thing what mics did
we use for all the music gear heads it
was a blue Bluebird pretty much for
everything how hard is it to film like
this it's actually pretty easy cuz uh
our technical crew back up back there
can we get a shot on them yeah they set
up everything you like they're probably
like kilometers of cables all connected
here and it took it took them hours to
set everything up there there's a lot
going on here it's kind of madness and
we greatly appreciate all the effort
going into this but it's kind of a
technical marvel so for us it's super
easy for them that might be a different
story maybe that we could do I I don't
know interview about that afterwards for
all the film production nerds yeah yeah
we could all see it on their face that
it wasn't the easiest thing to set up
and mastered and I didn't go and say to
himself for tech guys yeah but there's I
think tech people we kind of get like a
sick pleasure out of this like tedious
nerdy stuff yeah it's kind of like we
thrive on it
bring back the dog is the dog gone the
dogs gone the dog won't be coming back
we miss our we do have a pod we have a
vampire Diana I thought this was a
boxing room Oh see the next seems very
Bela Lugosi yes
shout out to the old smoke counterstrike
heads I agree I start playing in 2006
right when source was new shout out to
all of you guys you guys asked for it
and they delivered yes what just go here
we go here we go oh wait let's see you
like a family photo like let's like just
like need you in here - I love and NZ
it's always it's got a nice dog sneeze
right my mouth alright for Jay
there we go this is this is a JCPenney
family photo Olin Mills speak whatever
blankets back you should ask him about
his JCPenney family bachelor photos it's
a hilarious story we have returned it
however we do have to work tomorrow
because we're gonna produce the great
eye shadow you've ever seen tomorrow of
tune in TBS Conan O'Brien and only gets
better every channel right here in my
hand on my hand my hand right here the
the number of the show is gonna show up
right yeah
whatever state you're in right here
people are complaining that your shirts
no one can we're still on yeah they want
this shirt off yeah all right I'm not so
chroma keyed as I was before even kind
of see-through me yeah a little bit you
can tell that in my parents will vouch
for this wearing the shirt I have no
soul because I take the fork and take it
out high five for myself yeah yeah
because have a good time oh here's cute
gifts I sleep with this every night I'm
not joking
starting in December 2017 yes there's a
new addition to your lifestyle you
doesn't want to wear on it it does
O'Malley
if you put a black light on this thing
it lights up like a disco ball who can
say why touch Quest Tony going to be
here for performance tonight yeah
there's no need to sleep you have an
excuse as a Wahoo show up at 2:00 p.m.
tomorrow yeah you fit the color scheme
of the game pretty nicely
[Music]
see ya I believe you that you're from
Minnesota I've driven through Minnesota
I've never gotten out of my car there
but uh it was a large state I don't that
means
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what do you think of this game
it's pretty good it's kind of exciting
yeah and it matches the mood of the game
very nicely I like whatever we get to
Megaman later that's some of the most
classic video game music of all time we
were just talking about this in our
little office room that yesterday that
seems so long ago I have not really
slept since then because I was so
excited for this thing Monday night last
night that I really only slept about two
hours so about my fourth window I think
[Music]
today
yeah I drink a lot of coffee today
you're totally off caffeine good tea
doesn't quite count it's like it's like
caffeine light let's buy some skills
yeah we have a co-worker named skills
who produces all the music that you hear
on air in the show and deals alone all
the music year he is a wealth of
knowledge of many things
he's been on tour with some awesome
bands yeah there's so like you can't do
it justice because there's so much
detail he's worked with see Patti Smith
I think he told me he was on tour
chapterhouse
oh yes
there will be a web only performance on
Team Coco , they might be giants I saw
live in Baltimore in 2012 there was a
very good show we're gonna unlock some
rage venge here
quit that what else do we need
and get a steam Buster whatever oh yeah
that's whenever you kill somebody they
fly around and do more damage cool all
right let's see let's see you how far I
can get on this if I can harken back to
my glory days of playing this game the
key is to get a long streak going by
getting the enemies that you defeat them
keep bouncing people you kind of build
up the combo oh my god
is that for me is that from processor is
that from Jordans office behind the
couch it's a good question who can say
you never know
[Music]
yeah
so here's a good question how did you
[Music]
who's John de Bourgh former coworker
he's currently the editor of movie mag
which is uh they have some really good
articles just unique stuff I don't even
know how to classify kind of lifestyle
but also comedic it's good
check out actually compared to everybody
else I probably have like the least
common way of getting hired here and
that I applied through the website I was
it does actually work sometimes you can
get lucky yeah basically I was living in
Baltimore I was kind of ready to move on
from there was looking for something new
and while I was kind of refreshing on
the computer science concepts that I
learned in college I was watching a lot
of Conan that was the one show I would
let myself watch when I was interviewing
like this game there we go
and we're back yeah throughout all of
our development on Android I know how it
works in and out by this point but yeah
they say I just applied on the website
when I was ready for a job change they
happen to have a web developer posting
and according to Travis who is my boss
he said that I was the first person to
email who wasn't just trying to get a
comedy packet in I was actually applying
for the part that they were advertising
so I think that helped a lot and it also
helped that I had experience with
everything that was on there
so and then uh yeah I loaded up my car I
was briefly home and Pittsburgh and then
I drove from Pittsburgh out to Los
Angeles and found apartment from
Craigslist and I've loved it ever since
I really love working here it's great I
love Los Angeles it's fun what are your
criteria for getting rid of a beard I've
been thinking of getting rid of mine I
actually have I don't know what is your
criteria for getting rid of a beard I
shave there we go for me it's weird I
usually arbitrarily decide to start
growing one and then I'm really excited
about it for a long time and then one
day I will wake up and look in the
mirror and go oh my god that's what I
look like and then I shave it there's no
planning
there's no methodology it's just when it
stops feeling right Bridgeville
Pittsburgh and a man in the house what's
up
I'm from shawl ride just down the river
originally good to hear from you you're
either up very early or very late it's
Team Coco hiring now I'm not sure you
can always check the footer of Team Coco
calm but I don't think that there's
anything up there right now
[Music]
we're reading all the checks you're
trying to look at all there are so many
questions going on one side what's in
this snazzy orange coat of cuffs water
obviously at all times
the only option I think oh what a view
are we talking about earlier our ep that
is our ep we're in a band called the
change and that EP will be coming out in
the coming weeks right now we're only on
soundcloud we only have two songs out
loud but a few weeks it'll be like who
knows all the various places where you
listen to music Google Play Store
obviously you need to play an FPS game
we have any first-person shooters
they're kind of tricky to pull up and
I'm sure it could work I'm not really
investigated playing any other we're on
Twitter too we are on Twitter Twitter
Facebook and Instagram are a big social
space look up the Chang's la probably
find us do you still drive Kevin Hart
around every times that happens since
the initial taping you just like kick it
in an Oldsmobile yeah
he was just on the show and he was very
funny definitely go look up his the epic
super bowl story cuz if you were
watching the Super Bowl you probably saw
him getting kind of denied by the
security guards because he was trying to
get on the podium that's not a bit that
was real and he he tell us exactly what
was happening and let's just say a lot
of it was caused by a magic orange cup
coated water yeah let me ask you guys
yeah it's like it's uplifting but what
are your favorite video game soundtracks
of all time because I definitely have a
few I think my favorite at least
currently is Castlevania I've been
listening to that a lot Castlevania is
one two and four for Super Nintendo
there's some good renditions on Spotify
which I listen to in Google Play oh yeah
that's a great soundtrack yeah when I
think video game soundtracks I think
like 8-bit old school but uh Oh Chrono
Trigger soundtrack keep that dude that's
a good line
the opening theme nd I vaguely remember
that but I have heard it so wrong it's
like it's like four or five different
sections long oh wow an item when you're
in between times it's like that's like
one of my favorite songs
[Music]
Melda
oh yeah how Korea time is great love
that sounds Wow
I got likes it back into the earth
somehow like shrieking this is my advice
voice that no amount of seems like a bit
of a drag I've got a few things I was
kind of just arbitrarily going for it so
we have the bonus let's get an upgrade
ultra survival if you reach one
remaining heart you're next super will
be an ultra instead there's there's also
another game on Nova stores called tat
Titans yeah this is a little more like
skill-based that one is really I forget
what they they call those games kind of
like the famous cookie tapper game
I don't know it's called I'm sure you
guys probably know but uh oh no we lost
soundin oh now we're in the silence of
light oh it is back yes there we go
hi I understand we're not doing great at
this game but it is also kind of hard to
play something that like demands your
attention because it's constantly moving
and also continue talking
I'm trying we're going for it
that's yeah you're actually probably
right there you the only bad thing that
can happen you could run into spice and
that's like the only way you would
really die otherwise you would just kind
of get stuck in a wall that is a
possibility to see it always once you
start seeing those blue guys with the
shields that's when you know like the
difficulty starting to ramp up I don't
know if a good way to consistently beat
those guys so I tend to just jump over
them
[Music]
Fernando's watching from Australia
oh nice my neighbors are Australian
that's some common ground we have there
I don't know where they're from but uh
it's pretty small country I believe just
like a couple hundred people there so
you probably all know each other
[Music]
are there any easter eggs on the team
from
[Music]
there were as of recently until they
were rediscovered we kind of forgot
about them and they're fairly horrific
and I I don't know that any of them are
there anymore now that I think about it
actually if there any coders out there I
think there are a few loving notes in
the source code you can actually read
read some of my code comments which
might include profanity actually
typically do there we did heavy perhaps
ill-advised Robert Durst Easter Egg
where his face would pop on the screen
and start moving around and it would say
Durst alert very loudly that was back
when is that making a murderer or the
the the jinx
[Music]
and I think uh on the it so that the
Jewish Lansky generator if you click on
him enough times it will do a creepy
thing like if there are some some Easter
eggs day see
good night grind Bedard sweet tomatoes
to you as well
Silent Hill has a pretty good soundtrack
I have Kimber if I've ever played the
game and I remember the movie was pretty
creepy and that had a good soundtrack
representing Resident Evil that whole
series has pretty quality soundtracks
too especially the first game pc or
gaming console I tend to gravitate
towards PC so I lived my entire
conscious life at a computer basically
but consoles are fun as well especially
the older ones I recently got a
superintendent Classic and I've been
borrowing the team cocoa digital Super
Nintendo classic on weekends until I got
my own and that got the job done but I
tend to play more PC this is the girl
from the Kevin hard-driving remote Kevin
Hart and iced tea and cone air-raid
siren in the movie Silent Hill is
jacking up their life yes that was super
disturbing and I know what you're
talking about
[Music]
I'm sorry I think I asked you guys that
your favorite game soundtracks were that
I started playing so what other ones are
good Mega Man obviously Mega Man 2 great
soundtrack yeah one if we can now switch
up something I don't know which place
that's always around here somewhere we
have our tech crew on it yeah I'll go
one more did you hack your SNES classic
in what game so you put it I did not
hack it I want to beat all the games on
it properly first so I'm currently
working through super Castlevania 4 on
the hard mode 553 is a great soundtrack
yeah yeah a lot of the Square Enix games
have a really good music
where is Conan I assume Conan is taking
a nap right now or he's just like
lingering out boomer Warner Brothers
parking lot tend to do that could be
check it in stay tuned for that
[Music]
Oh cuphead help that has a great
soundtrack it's very like 1920s kind of
big-band jazz swing that's one of my
favorite games in recent memory and I
played that on PC very frustrating
though but I did beat it I was proud of
myself there Zelda - I've actually never
played solitude but I know that's a
controversial in the Zelda lineage doom
has a good soundtrack girls sing to that
in the office whenever we were having
our conversation embodies doom on body's
doom there's not much body going on here
there we go and we were switching over
to Megaman sure why not one of my
favorite game series of all time it's
incredibly frustrating super difficult
and that's what's fun about it I feel
like kids these days the games are just
made to guide you to victory obviously
with the exception of Dark Souls but
let's see we're gonna play normal speed
because uh I'm not actually that good
even though I talk a lot of trash so uh
a key component of playing megaman is
knowing the proper order to play the
levels in if you guys can help advise on
that I do believe that it's usually wise
to start off with a cut man and then
after that I couldn't
forget it so let's get together let's go
so I like come in a little speed I like
all the intros yeah they get there a
little posing moment like it's
professional
yeah it's like I haven't even gotten I
haven't even died yet and I'm already
just like frustrated
I don't like anticipation I know that
the antagonist is dr. wily
and he has some evil intentions I think
he created all the robots that you see
that are trying to take you down there
and you're created by a good doctor
named dr. light I do believe that's
correct
feel free to correct me if I'm wrong
there but uh guessing doctor like
created Mega Man specifically with the
purpose of defeating widely and I'm sure
after that the story is getting more
involved I'm not a huge story guy when
it comes to video games I like the
simplicity of these older games I
recently played like one of the big
games from 2016 on my PC and there were
so many cutscenes and story that I
couldn't even comprehend or follow I'm
just just getting to the game get beyond
give me a shooting a blaster and evil
helicopters with grinning faces diving
at me and I'm good to go but I
understand if you if you like that's
really it's just a not really
have you played any of the Megaman games
this is the original
I think Mega Man for Nintendo is the
first Megaman game to come out there
might be an earlier version on some
obscure system but this is the one kind
of everybody started to know it really
became popular with Megaman
[Music]
you have to eat it's really got to get
rid of every enemy on the screen
sometimes it makes things easier it's
unnecessary
[Music]
it took me a little bit but I'm actually
getting quite used to playing this on
the tablet oh yeah like the spacing
feels a lot like an original NES
controller like they really nailed kind
of the dimensions of that but I also
have pretty big hand
so maybe other people would disagree it
probably also depends on your tablet but
it's it's pretty great like I couldn't
have imagined as a kid having original
Mega Man so fun to go to the cool
[Music]
that guy's missing Oh
sometimes you just gotta run who's gonna
make peace with the fact that you're not
gonna solve every conflict these guys do
don't have a ton of healthsome probably
about to get screwed by this first boss
[Music]
I wish it Peter
like if you keep all these
yeah that would be convenient I think is
a Mega Man 3 where he gets the ability
to slide if you're wondering why i just
died there without even trying it's
because i had no health and i just would
rather restart it well
you can't see the health of power-walk
oh well I was yeah I think the nice
thing about this mental game is it's a
little more forgiving than the original
they give you unlimited lives oh yeah
that the health is at the bottom of the
screen which is just kind of cut off a
little bit there but as I went into that
final boss battle I only had two little
sluggers and there was really no chance
of me making any progress this should go
a little better this time
I should have this go understand
I mean Megaman keeps you awake because
you end up getting so angry it's like
you're not going to be able to realize
there we go I think you should take the
artist level so what should we play next
someone's suggest we should
to me suggestions
we just be cut man's you need to move on
from there I think a good option might
be Iceman I think I Spit stuff maybe
bomb and or guts man
I mean that's not the harissa
that's the next
we were in the bathroom that we'll be
right back so it's just you and me and
Megaman Oh
[Music]
I'm rusty I might not be able to talk to
you Chad ISM I needn't go because I'm
not dying
[Music]
so where's everybody from I'm from North
Carolina
they're ready from North Carolina
[Music]
no people recognize me
hey Kevin Hart
[Music]
some people say
[Music]
your wife yes yes but I'm stuck
but I'm alive we're still alive all
right or if you go to Iceman
[Music]
what do we think those things in the
background are I've always kind of
wondered that in look like buildings but
very practical buildings maybe like
power generators or something yeah
there's water
yes thank you camera guys I agree
[Music]
yeah try some Jolt Cola I haven't seen
Joel :
so is that still a thing do they make
that
[Music]
someone suggested a futon
I think you should do I do sure this is
probably the hardest game yeah this is
not easy like it's not easy on Nintendo
or any of the PC iterations but the nice
thing about this version is they start
you kind of on the screen or you died
whereas I think the original
there's usually a checkpoint like
halfway through and then you just have
to start back from there regardless of
how much further past you get
these guys
like there should be some copyright
infringement against the Mario bullet
bills I don't know if it's intentional
but uh
they look very similar to me
[Music]
thank you I never thought about that
Megaman and Mario you gonna really do
wow that was
that's just that didn't happen nobody
address that and shet nobody saw that
jump it's gonna be fine here I didn't
even do it I don't know if you're
talking about Oh No Wow and they start
you huff you a little farther that's I
like that back in 1997 vaguely yeah
alright let's switch to up there yeah a
nice extra life
it's always fun to switch to use the
different weapons even if it's like
impractical for this situation everybody
knows in Megaman 2 the metal blade is
like the best weapon and any of the
Megaman games to be really cool
I don't know what tragic spike jump
you're talking about that must have been
someone who played earlier in the to
cocoa Google play 24 hour livestream
marathon
certainly wasn't game
I just jump yeah there we go
[Music]
[Music]
this stuff is nothing but an excuse
[Music]
one more hit come on there we go
two bosses down
[Music]
we can do this just on the tablet we've
already got two of the bosses though the
true Mega Man fans out there know that
the yellow devil would be very difficult
we have a name for this head
[Music]
looks like a Glenn to me Glenn Glenn for
Glenn sandy metal fans out there you
kinda looks like Devin Townsend you
agree you see him tearing up some logic
guitar screaming at you
[Music]
somebody seemed to be really sad people
I think one is actually doing better
than you think I think this this is a
natural default state and this is what
he wants to be yeah he's very better
than anybody else you see so far is
there a team cocoa gaming just for
there's not it's a cool idea though we
have any shows coming up regarding the
Shang's
we do it the live show coming up April
12th I forget exactly where the name of
the venue but it's in Los Angeles we'd
love to see you there if you say that
you're from the stream I'll get you a
drink you're late
that could backfire or blable will save
[Music]
the head looks like powder for movie
powder total thing yeah I remember
does he get like electrocuted by a
Jacob's Ladder or something
I only bigger than that's been so long
but anyways we're at the top of the hour
let's check in with Cohen welcome I'm
very fortunate I've got fans all over
the world and they send me cool things
sometimes check this out I got this from
a fan in Russia this is beautifully
handmade it's a Russian nesting doll and
there's I think I believe that's moss
isn't Moscow might be Moscow yes Moscow
on once said that you turn it around and
look who's there they put a crazy weird
Conan with a beard on this Russian
nesting doll now as you know with
Russian nesting dolls there's always
another doll inside and then another
doll and then another doll because what
we're gonna do okay I'm gonna reveal
what other dolls are in here one an hour
which doll was coming up next this is
fantastic
call your friends waking him up new
Russian nesting doll each hour the first
ones Conan let's see
there he was thanks codon
Thank You Conan so now we're starting
afresh our it is now yeah we're going
strong
we're approaching the home stretch of
this all thanks for being with us this
stream we're cycling it so you might see
a little disruption on the YouTube side
of things if you're on YouTube switch to
it we're gonna start a new video
yeah as we've been doing throughout the
stream so this one's gonna stop just go
back to our channel page and you've been
refined look for you part six on YouTube